brian the other big story here at five
o'clock we're hearing from neighbors
that were inside of a henderson
apartment complex
during a shooting that killed four
people it happened yesterday morning
near stephanie and wigwam at the douglas
at stone lake apartments
and that's where we find 8 news now
reporter kate houston who has an update
for us kate
yes i'm just outside of the apartment
complex and where we are you can
actually
see the area where this shooting
occurred
caution tape that blocked off residents
yesterday is no longer there
and while it may look back to normal a
resident tells me neighbors are still
traumatized
now shots were heard by residents as
henderson police were on scene
responding to reports of a shooting
henderson police say they tried to make
contact with the suspect
but in doing so were forced to use their
weapons overall four people are dead
including the suspect
another is injured i spoke to a resident
who did not want to be identified
but she tells me there have been a few
disputes in the complex
but nothing of this magnitude and since
it's a family residence
she says it's very unsettling it's sad
it's alarming you know there is a little
trauma the next day like wow did this
just happen yesterday was it so close to
my home
and you know there's a level of safety
that
has now been tarnished
the resident tells me it's a tight-knit
community and many are worried
for the residents that were right next
to that shooting they are planning to
hold a community gathering to support
those who have been emotionally impacted
in the meantime though they are
searching for answers and we are still
awaiting the names of
the people who were shot as well as the
person shot by henderson police we'll
give you that information as soon as we
know more
reporting live tonight from stephanie in
wigwam in henderson kate houston 8 news
now